the driver of this car was lucky he
almost drowned in the flood waters of
the ice-river but help came just in time
I came from the other side the sign was
the wrong way round
he didn't look deep from either empty if
I just thought four days southern and
eastern Germany have been battling
floods more and more dikes are bursting
inundating homes streets and fields
farmers faced massive losses from ruined
harvests the emergency services can do
little to stem the water meteorologists
say a persistent low pressure over the
Alps is to blame it's also causing heavy
rain in Switzerland traffic on the Rhine
near Ryan Felton has been halted the
floodwaters are heading downstream and
water levels just keep rising parts of
Austria are preparing themselves for the
worst
firefighters are building mobile
protective dams along the banks of the
Danube in the coming days heavy strong
rain is expected here and the river is
already at the limit it's a different
picture entirely in the far north of
Europe near the Arctic Circle and
northern Sweden people are enjoying
unusually warm May weather with
temperatures hitting 26 degrees Celsius
a record for the month